hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Rick and Morty season 3
episode 3 cycle Rick this episode was
just pure ridiculous fun but pickle rick
side adventure was actually rooted
firmly in this episode's deeper theme so
i'm going to get into that plus all the
subtle jokes and references that you
might have missed or if you are as much
of an obsessed superfan as I am and you
already caught all this stuff let's just
relive together everything that made
this up so great cool like no one has to
be smarter than anyone else okay let's
get started opening images right away in
the bathroom there's a quick shot of the
former family dog snuffles aka snowball
from the first season now this whole
idea of Rick turning himself into a
pickle is a crazy move that we've been
waiting to see since the trailer even as
far back as that animated storyboard a
pickle ray from over a year ago but
let's be clear here despite what it
seems
pickle Rick isn't a random thing in fact
to be pickled is another way of saying
to be drunk like soaked in alcohol at
least according to urban dictionary and
a few creative alcoholics that I know in
fact that might be why pickle Rick begin
to episode by lying on his face so when
you look at things that way pickle rick
is another metaphor for how Rick escapes
addressing his problems in a healthy way
he turns himself into a pickle to avoid
therapy just like how he soaks himself
in booze to avoid thinking about the
meaninglessness of life of course Rick
hates self reflection so much that after
the opening credits he specifically
refuses to let Morty even think about it
new pickles live forever or he stopped
digging for hidden layers and just be
impressed I'm a pickle I'm just trying
to figure out why you would do this why
anyone would do this the reason anyone
would do this if they could which they
can't would be because they could which
they can't I also like our Rick
references the internet video meme of
cats freaking out of cucumbers oh I know
what it looks like to you is eat but I'm
not a snake I've seen the YouTube videos
I know cats are scared of cucumbers and
pickles because they think they're
snakes now in case you didn't know this
I certainly didn't cap thinking they're
snakes is actually the reason National
Geographic actually ran an article about
this quoting certified animal
behaviorist Jill Goldman who said that
it is wrong to stress out cats with
cucumbers shaped stink and then when
rick rolled down the Sun notice how he
says this can't really be
go out this is a mega-genius equivalent
of dying on the toilet so this is a
reference to the common misperception of
Elvis Presley being found dead on the
toilet which he wasn't he was just in
his bathroom but there are other famous
historical figures like Catherine the
Great and Lenny Bruce who did reportedly
died on the toilet then Rick's load
sounded the sewer which the writers
actually said is a reference to the
movie Pikeville goes west but in this
version the rats get frickin slaughters
and then after Rick uses the nerve
endings of dead cockroaches to move such
as very fun phrase to say we move on to
dr. Wong's office and if you look at her
store the sign says family therapy and
Co prophase II Oh recovery copra Fei Jie
is the term for the consumption of feces
which is exactly what Morty's teacher
mr. goldenfold is been there for how
long have you all been eating poop
we have never eaten poop
I like how dr. Wong turns over the
motivational poster for dedication which
has a picture of a family obviously for
the patients awaiting family therapy
from the side that says courage and a
picture of a guy eating the hot dog
which I assume is for the copra fascia
patients I guess have the courage to eat
something other than poop next we see a
full color version of that awesome scene
that we saw in the animated storyboard
you'll notice that all the rats are
depicted as these monstrous beasts the
animators said that they did that so
that we wouldn't become emotionally
attached to the rats so that we wouldn't
behind when Rick tears them apart and I
just want to take a moment to point out
all the other animation details of the
odds and ends that Rick used to Tony
Stark his way to freedom
Rick brings up this guillotine similar
to the one that he had in his garage
earlier then he uses this heavy severed
rat's head to press down a bottle cap
which operates this ridiculous machinery
consisting of chopsticks and it looks
like the blades taken out of an exacto
knife also I know this is super gory but
when Rick slices the rat in half you can
make out all the anatomical details of
the inside the rat okay moving on this
episode takes a turn become a really
great diehard parody pickle Rick begins
invoking the action hero Bruce Willis's
John McClane just a regular pickle cot
in the pickle he sneaks around in the
air vents of an office building he takes
out the guards one by one and uses these
DIY remedies to heal himself
and both of these in with the dramatic
images of a helicopter taking off a roof
and a massive explosion and back the way
Rick taught the guy in charge is almost
a direct nod to the way McClane first
interacts with Hans Gruber over the
radio Jack you are Jack work that's what
I told all of you I want a radio silence
until said sorry Hans and get that
message now the voice actor this
character is Peter Serafinowicz you may
know him from sound of dead he also did
the voice of Darth Maul here he seems to
be doing a vocally vocation of Alan
Rickman character in die hard Hans
Gruber speaking of vocal cameos this
episode Susan Sarandon does the voice of
dr. Wong and Danny Trejo is amazing as
the assassin jagwire now a few other
action movie references here I'd love
this point of view shot of Rick taken
through the wounds of the people we just
killed in a similar shot in China of
dead it also shows up in Deadpool and a
bunch of other movies Rick also uses the
old using a second phone to redirect the
call trick that Liam Neeson used and
taken and if you look closely at the guy
in charge of this key card it has this
word in Russian letters which literally
just translates to the Russian word for
key and I love this episode's mythology
around the fictional Russian folklore
figure of Selenia the pickle man which
obviously isn't a real thing these guys
believe that it punishes wasteful
children and I notice what this guy says
he's coming [ __ ] because I true
prop way my sandwich actually this
half-eaten sandwich shows the blade of
this episode Rick uses a pickle from
that sandwich to patch up his wound
there's also a quick reference to a past
episode when Rick says this to Jaguar in
fact I even abandoned one of my infinite
daughter's in an alternate version of
Earth that was taken over by mutant this
of course is a reference to the show's
original c-137 universe that got
Cronenberg in fact morty and summer just
revisited this place in the season 3
premiere and based on that shot of the
two summers that has been added to the
season 3 opening credits I feel like we
might be going back to this place
another place it sounds like they might
be going back to is Shoni which we
learned in the first episode is Rick's
favorite restaurant that brings it up in
the final line of this episode so what
do you think in like smoky tavern maybe
Shoni but let's touch back on what this
episode is all about summed up
surprisingly well by dr. Wong you seem
to alternate between viewing your own
mind as an unstoppable force and as
an inescapable curse and I think it's
because the only truly unapproachable
concept for you is that it's your mind
within your control I have no doubt that
you would be bored senseless by therapy
because the thing about repairing
maintaining and cleaning is it's not an
adventure it's just work and the bottom
line is some people are okay going to
work and some people well some people
would rather die to summarize this point
rick is an example of how some super
gifted individuals don't know how to
take care of themselves because they see
mental and emotional health as work
boring routine self maintenance keeping
themselves healthy and balanced is not
enough of a thrill or a challenge for
them it's actually interesting that in
this episode Rick brought up other super
talented artists who died on toilets
Elvis Presley again that's just a myth
Saul so Lenny Bruce like Rick these
people put creative pursuits in front of
their own help and in the end it caused
their own premature death Rick says the
same thing here just to avoid therapy
Rick constructs this elaborate pointless
challenge for him to get out of and
while he does acknowledge his family's
problems by eventually showing up to
this therapy session dr. Wong's advice
doesn't stick the episode ends with Rick
remaining a toxic influence notice how
when Morty says that he likes dr. Wong
both Rick and Beth totally ignore him
and instead they make plans to
completely drown their problems in
alcohol Rick may have transforms back
into a human physically but he remains
soaked in booze a pickle Rick now before
I go into the post-credits scene many of
you have pointed out that this is one of
the few episodes that doesn't at all
feature jerry's now hopefully this won't
be a season long thing remember in last
episode jerry did say that they'll be
seeing him every other week in this
divorce settlement so maybe that's how
the show plans to use them too we'll see
you next week okay on to the post
credits scene of Rick and Morty's runnin
with the terrifying villain concerto who
smashes his victims skulls with the
Hammers of a giant grand piano I gotta
say when this image showed up in the
season 3 trailer and in the opening
credits I was really excited to see what
this whole episode would be so I'm a
little bummed to see it as just a
30-second scene after the credits but
it's still cool to see it along yes now
concerto is playing Beethoven's
moonlight sonata which not to be too
technical but it's not a concerto but I
love conservative film
pun and the return of Jaguar and now for
the east black Jaguar but Rick's final
line here connects us back to the theme
that I just talked about that Morty is
why you don't go to therapy let's be
honest this is not a good enough reason
to not go to therapy fact Jaguar coming
in to rescue Rick here is pretty much a
coincidence really Rick is just once
again trying to justify his fear of
healing himself with this bonkers
adventure do you think that deep down
Rick might have taken any of dr. Wong's
advice do you want him to take this
advice and do you think pickle Rick
delivered on the hype I absolutely think
it did but I hear some of you who are
saying that maybe they showed too much
of this scene in the promotional
material let me know your thoughts down
below you can tweet at me directly at EA
vas or at our channel at new rock stars
now we're going to try to keep these
Rick and Morty breakdowns coming
throughout the season still can't make
any promises we're super busy but you
can help by keeping those positive vibes
coming and sharing this video far and
wide you can also help by subscribing to
new rock stars and by contributing to us
on patreon to help us make more of these
videos big thanks by the way to all of
our current donors especially pony stars
thanks for watching and hopefully see
you next week bye bye